now the four day strike by Junior
doctors this week will cause
unparalleled levels of disruption that's
according to NHS leaders the health
services National medical director has
told Sky News he's very concerned about
the potential impact on patients in
hospitals if the strike goes ahead and
the health secretary has accused doctors
the leaders of taking a militant stance
in their pay demands joining me now is
Dr Vivek Trivedi he's the co-chair of
the bma's junior doctors committee Dr
trevetti thank you so much for talking
to us so is it a strike is the strike
going ahead
as it stands the strike is going ahead
we wrote to Mr Barkley uh towards the
end of last week that he has the power
to avert these strikes all we were
hoping to do is for him to take us
seriously and present a credible offer
for us to start a basis of negotiations
he has the ability to stop the strikes
and it's a shame that he's refusing to
meet with us to do this okay well um bro
he would say that he is taking it
seriously and this is Stephen Buckley
I'm quoting he has said that
unfortunately the decision by the BMA
Junior doctors leaders to maintain an
unrealistic position meant we were
unable to make progress with talks it
seems they are intent on maintaining a
militant stance rather than working with
the government in a NHS management to
meet the best interests of their members
out of patients so he's saying not only
is it your fault as you're maintaining
an unrealistic position
that's why you couldn't there was no
progress in the talks and
um Junior doctors leaders are intent on
maintaining a militant stance
well I would disagree with that so in
our talks that we had on the 22nd of
March after our first set of strikes we
put out our opening position which is in
the public domain and has not changed
all we're looking to do is to reverse
the pay cuts that we've had since 2008
and go back to neutral just to go back
to Net Zero and not only did he refuse
to give us a counteroffer of a credible
nature on how we may go about addressing
this erosion he didn't give us a
counteroffer at all so I think it's
completely disingenuous for him to
suggest that we're the ones not willing
to negotiate when it's clearly him
that's um refusing to do this so you're
asking for 35 what counteroffer would
you accept
so what we've said to him for him to
stop the strikes is a credible offer
which acknowledges the erosion that
doctors have gone through we've lost
more than 26 of our pay and we just want
something that shows are you serious and
and also a clear path to negotiations
that we can go down to try and recoup
what we've lost over the last 15 years
how what do you say to someone who's
reading all of this and saying okay you
want a 35 pay rise I can't get to my
cancer check I can't get to my cancer
appointment and you want 35 Barclay says
that that would mean doc junior doctors
would receive more than 20 000 pounds
extra a year
I apologize to anyone that has any
appointments uh canceled or postponed
because of our action next week and you
mentioned Cancer Care what we've seen is
we've allowed us to get into a position
where we're failing the public already
we're already missing Cancer Care
deadlines because we don't have enough
staff to to see these patients in a
timely manner and helping to restore our
pay so not a pay rise just to restore
our pay is is one of the main ways that
we can do this and so I would urge Mr
Barkley to please come to the table
accept our offers to talk and we can
hopefully come to a resolution as
quickly as possible do you accept what
he says he says I'm concerned these
strikes carry a considerable risk to
patient safety do you accept that your
strikes do that I accept that the
strikes will cause a level of disruption
but as we saw in our 72 hour strikes we
were able to strike safely with the with
the help and cover of senior doctors
like consultants and Specialty doctors
across the across the country I'm
covering for junior absences so senior
officials within the BMA are in close
contact with senior officials in NHS
England to ensure that um appropriate
processes are being put into place to
allow this level of um to allow an
appropriate level of patient care and
patient cover over our 96 hour strikes
this coming week but again it's in Mr
Barkley's gift to avert these strikes
all we want is a credible offer on the
table okay Dr Trivedi thank you so much
for talking to us thank you